[Music]
yeah that
that's noah cyrus all grown up and
looking
gorge in a sexy bedazzled bodysuit at
the 2020 cmt awards
[Music]
the 20 year old musician hit the stage
with jimmy allen on wednesday night
to perform their collab this is us
[Music]
jimmy kicked off the performance in a
glittering silver coat and black pants
then noah really turned heads when she
entered the stage in a show-stopping
sheer bodysuit
complete with some strategically placed
jewels
noah accessorized the sexy number with a
sparkly white hat
gloves and thigh-high boots
i know everyone's going to be knocking
my door down and this look is a far cry
from noah's ensemble earlier in the
night
when she arrived on the blue carpet
wearing denim over an orange crop top
our next performance comes from two
young artists who come from very
different worlds
the duo's performance was introduced by
matchbox 20 front man
rob thomas who just so happens to be one
of jimmy's
musical idols she grew up when her
father's country hits
and he says that my music helped inspire
him so she took our country roots and
they led her to pop music
and he took his rock and pop and that
got him all the way into country music
so we get to see what that sounds like
when you put it
all together right now please welcome
jimmy allen and noah cyrus
and it's safe to say it sounded freaking
[Music]
great
now noah says there's another country
star she's dying to work with
i love casey casey of course being casey
musgraves
i really look up to her and her music
and i think she's super inspiring for
not only a ton of women but represents
everybody
and that's what i really love about
casey and back in may when e.t caught up
with noah's dad
billy ray cyrus he opened up about life
in quarantine and
said it might just be time for an entire
cyrus family collab
you have quite the musical family i mean
it's just amazing when are we gonna see
the cyruses
all get together for a jam session a
collaboration billy ray
i think you're seeing it right now it's
it's actually happening
it's it's all in the in the box it's all
in it
it all at this point is one big
[Music]
collaboration